this could be the first time for 69
months when will actually see some
dissent some some votes for a rate hike
from the independent members of the MPC
patently the the Bank of England embers
are still gonna be in line and not
voting for a rate hike but I think we're
going to start seeing that process and
two perhaps three perhaps miles will in
this last mission go for a rate hike
although that would be quite a vole fast
for him what we've seen in the past is
you have the the minutes being released
at different time from the quarterly
inflation report and there might be some
small discrepancy between the two which
bestest then starts to scrutinize and
don't really understand why that's going
on and now we're going to have all of
the all of the decision-making minutes
we're going to have the forecasts we're
gonna have the voting record all at once
and we can kind of piece those together
a much more consistent way we need to
focus more on it the eye of investment
rather than the eye for interest rates i
think interest rates are going to move
up whether it's September december
january I don't think really matters a
huge amount because when Yellen decides
and then the Fed decides they're going
to put ribs up it'll be a very positive
signal because they've been very nervous
about putting rips up for a very long
period of time
you
the difference is the Bank of England
uses macro-prudential policy whereas the
states they don't use that so there's
more of a crutch or mother an excuse to
not raise rates in UK because we've got
the ability to use microprobe I think
it's a mistake can I interest rate ought
to be higher bought and that perhaps
explains the reason why the disconnect
between those two markets the markets
pricing may next year for the first rate
hike we think that's when it's fully
priced we think it's more likely to come
in February mainly because we think the
UK economy is running out of slack there
is the possibility if the Fed goes in
September there is the possibility that
the bank Amin could go in November
against that is the fact that your
headline inflation is really low it
doesn't really start picking up until
the start of next year so it would be
quite surprising if they went to
November but if it goes in September
there is no massive market reaction to
that then the banking in my cat will
okay they've done it we should follow
suit